it comes a time in every man's life but
I just take you know that putting one
right and some that take it at the
bathroom I could show you what the hell
happened in the 1970s let's go back and
make three rudderless families the
Joneses with a Big Kahuna's on the block
the whole house was a disaster movie in
the making
welcome to the club men my family was
stuck right in the middle of the
cul-de-sac dad mr. Marsh with a super8
camper I captured everything in the hope
I could edit together called swinging
Safari ami
what was going through our poor
misguided heads why were they doing that
to each other we just go to school like
normal
[Music]
the pill sweetheart if father and I said
it's time what are we playing poker
everybody else has alcoholic bottle
blonde cocktails our parents did the
best they could with the bent tools they
were handed it's like you might have
earned yourself a blood tiger
[Music]
roll down a Catholic boarding schools
the priests will have their wired
[Music]
you